let's leave the youth movement and
representation and move now to art
because as we saw earlier an artist has
rolled his way to glasgow with the hope
of encouraging people to protect the
environment but can art really inspire
change
days what did you think did you see him
in his metal ball
yes and i absolutely loved it and
weirdly enough that's not the only
really important installation that's
happening at cop and there are many like
for example the air pollution pods which
have taken air pollution from many
different parts of the world um and have
created like an insulation that people
can basically go into feeling you know
what it's like to be in london versus
what's like to be in sweden and feel the
difference within our air quality um so
i think that's particularly important to
bring arts and also as an artist myself
i work at a local nature reserve um as
an artist in residence
and
going through and seeing how people can
connect back to
um the climate and our mother earth
and this being the sphere for their
action that they take on climate change
is truly important um also work within
theater and i'm currently working on a
production um with boundless theater
talking about how can we save the planet
when we are broke and we are young um
and there's something that's quite
amazing about this because it connects
um the idea of climate and the issues on
climate right round to the social issues
um that we face within society that's
aimed towards bringing community into
action with understanding where they sit
within the solutions to climate change
art is a very powerful tool and we
should not mistake it as not
sam what do you think do you think art
can raise awareness and
in turn uh impact policy
i think art can raise awareness i think
often you know through some you know
very
vivid imagery can cut through to
audiences that maybe
political messages or a speech from a
politician sometimes can't so
um i think it can really you know bring
to life some of the threats and some of
the challenges we face from
environmental degradation i mean i
recently to give an example went to see
the wildlife photographer of the year
exhibition and there saw some really
haunting imagery of what we're doing in
terms of habitat degradation and
destruction so i think it can be really
powerful for highlighting some of the
challenges
but i do think that you know ultimately
the the challenge of solving these
problems we need to channel that concern
which i think does exist at quite a high
level already among the public for
around issues like climate change and
habitat loss into specific policies
which ultimately will help us deal with
the challenge and i think they're you
know engaging people with some of the
potential solutions some of the
technologies that we're going to have to
adopt and what that might mean for their
lives as well as incentivizing them
financially to take up some of those
technologies and shift their behavior um
i think
that's a really key part of getting that
positive response right but i think art
can play
an important role right at the start and
in getting people engaged and interested
and aware of some of the challenges
just briefly dave do you think that art
is somewhere where um the youth can
actually come and uh interact with
climate change
definitely and i think that we should
start expanding what we call art because
art isn't just you know the physical
visual painting but it's the writing
it's the poetry it's the songs you know
it's the protest and i always say you
know protests are one big production um
you know there is visually beautiful
things that happen at protest i think
even today with the making of signs and
people expressing their grief their
fears but also their joy and their love
of the planet through different kinds um
i think something that young people are
doing very well okay fantastic well an
exciting week ahead of us days sam thank
you so much for talking to us